my mom was followed by a murderer and
this is that story
all right so this story goes all the way
back to the mid-1970s
so this is my mom's junior year of high
school well it was the end of her junior
year of high school i guess i should say
actually it was the start of her summer
vacation it was a beautiful day so my
mom
her sister and her friend decided to
take a little day trip so the three of
them hop in the car
and they're off so it takes them about
two and a half hours to get there
they're listening to the radio talking
about things they want to do for the
summer
and eventually they arrive at their
destination oak creek canyon park
so for context this trip and this entire
story is all taking place in northern
arizona
the park they're at sits in the middle
of coconino national forest
so one of the main reasons they wanted
to go to this park is because it's
absolutely gorgeous over there
there's trees mountains one of the
things they notice when they get there
is that it is
very open almost too open so they park
their car in a small parking lot and
they start scoping out an area for them
to hang out they end up plopping down
with a small pond by the park
with plans to just hang out for a few
hours they had brought some food
they were maybe going to do a picnic
they didn't really know other than the
fact that they were just enjoying that
summer had just begun
i feel like it's important to mention
that my mom has been to this park before
she's been there a few times with some
friends and whatnot but it was very
empty that day
which was strange for such a nice day
anyway so there they are just hanging
out
when suddenly my mom notices a man
across the pond a couple of minutes go
by and my mom's sitting there
trying to stay engaged in the
conversation with her sister when she
stares back across the pond
the man is still standing there he's
staring at them
rubbing his chin thoughtfully like i see
you
obviously my mom's first thought is what
the hell is this guy doing out here by
himself and
why is he staring at us like that trying
her best not to stare back
she does a few quick glances at best and
she notices his clothes
he's really well dressed which is just
another weird detail that didn't seem to
add up to my mom
we should just move to another area i'm
getting really creeped out she thought
to herself
after deciding that the situation isn't
normal she gets the attention of her
sister and her friend
pointing out the man staring at them
across the pond they tell her she's
overthinking it and she's just being
crazy
he's probably there just enjoying the
park like anyone else would it is a
public park after all and you know they
were probably right
people are allowed to be outside people
are allowed to go to public parks
whatever still feeling uneasy my mom
tries her best to go back to just
enjoying her day
out of the corner of her eye she notices
a slight
movement instantly her eyes dart back
across the pond
the man isn't there anymore suddenly she
catches sight of the man
he's walking along the edge of the pond
headed their direction
the scariest part he was walking with
intention
he was walking toward them and to my mom
that was it so as to not escalate the
situation any further because my mom had
no idea what was going to happen
my mom softly but sternly pointed out
the man walking across the pond
finally they all agreed that something
wasn't right about this situation
and that they should move now as quickly
and quietly as they could
they gathered their things and headed
back to the car all the while my mom is
sneaking glances at him he was still
there
walking with an even quicker pace than
he was before closing in on where they
had just been seconds before my mom will
say to this day
she had the worst feeling in the pet of
her stomach she was practically
hyperventilating
out of fear instinct caution whatever
you want to call it my mom picks up a
rock on the way to the car they reach
the car
they throw their stuff in the trunk and
they pile in my mom is hunched over in
the back seat clutching the rock for
dear
life she peeks out the back window as
the car starts
she doesn't see him
wherever he was they needed to get out
of there with the tires practically
squealing out of the parking lot
they raced down the same road they drove
in on at this point everyone's eyes are
glued to the rear view mirror
so that was weird my mom thought to
herself
rock in hand my mom was definitely
shaken up my mom's sister the one who
was driving the car
quickly looks in the rearview mirror and
she says oh my god
look the energy in the air it felt cold
it just felt wrong slowly my mom peers
out the back window one more time
to her horror she sees a car emerging
from the same parking lot
following them she'll never forget the
feeling of watching a yellowish
cream-colored volkswagen beetle slowly
gaining ground on them
now everyone was truly terrified
what did this person want why was he
following them all my mom knew was
this person is evil she could feel it
her sister floors the gas pedal
and luckily they're able to maintain a
distance between themselves and this man
eventually they get to a gas station and
they pull over to what they hope
is safety to their surprise and
ultimately their relieved
the man drives right by them my mom
my mom's sister and her friend they were
all really unsettled by the whole thing
now you're probably wondering why i just
told you that story please don't go
anywhere
i'm about to explain the craziest part
so about 15 years go by
my mom's just at home minding her in
business watching the news
when she sees that convicted serial
killer ted bundy is about to be
sentenced to death
she's watching the news learning more
about this man and she learns that he
was well dressed
he drove a yellow cream-colored
volkswagen beetle
and he committed several murders in
colorado which is right above arizona
and as she's watching the news the phone
rings
my mom's sister my aunt who was with her
when this happened all those years ago
is watching the same broadcast when she
calls my mom
and without even saying hello the very
first thing my aunt says is
do you think it was him and without
missing a beat my mom slowly says
i know it was him for the majority of my
childhood the holidays were the scariest
time of year for me
because my family was cursed this is
that story
it all started when i was five years old
my mom's sunday school class was raising
money for a charity so
she had our class make christmas
ornaments using white glue and glitter
all of the ornaments were bought by
churchgoers except for one ornament
this ornament was supposed to be a bell
with a peace sign in it very christmassy
but it actually ended up looking more
like darth vader
not very christmassy well my mom felt
bad so she bought it herself
we should have been suspicious that no
one wanted this ornament
from that holiday season on we always
hung that ornament on our tree
unless we hung that ornament on our tree
for every holiday season or something
could do onto like without a second
thought or like nevertheless we hung the
ornament on our tree without a second
thought
[Music]
oddly enough we started having really
bad luck around thanksgiving and
christmas
no i'm trying to look right at the
camera
no problem
say hi we're trying to record a video
about
a christmas curse we're just starting to
talk about the curse
element of it and the camera keeps
shutting off
like something doesn't want this story
to be told
i'm not gonna say anything else i'm just
telling you what's happening
every year every year we could count on
something bad happening
for example our dog passed away the day
after thanksgiving
my grandpa had to have emergency surgery
my cat passed away the day after
christmas my dad was actually
misdiagnosed with a heart attack and
ended up having to have
emergency back surgery we lived in new
jersey
bad stuff happened we moved across the
country to oregon
bad stuff continued to happen so now
it's 2004 and i'm in seventh grade my
mom's parents
my grandparents had come into town for
the holidays when i was growing up a
modern term
to describe my mom and grandma would
probably be pinterest queens
the whole house always looked beautiful
there were garlands and twinkle lights
and it was like living in a movie
amongst these beautiful decorations was
that
weird darth vader ornament cut to
christmas morning i'm awake and i'm
ready to unwrap what i was hoping
was a fashion poly bedroom set so my
sister and i were raised not to leave
our rooms until
mom or dad told us to come downstairs
for christmas they just wanted some
peace and quiet in the morning before
all hell broke loose
i'm sitting in bed anxiously awaiting to
demolish some pretty wrapping paper when
i hear my mom yell from down the stairs
now this should have been an exciting
moment because it meant christmas was
ready but
it was a different kind of yell it
sounded more like a cry of pain
then i heard her shout don't come down
the stairs followed by
a bunch of bangs and thuds
[Music]
sorry to interrupt the video but the
reason you're looking at me right now
and not
jackie is because when i went to edit
this footage altogether
half of the footage was missing could
this be some sort of technical error
maybe could it be my fault also maybe
it's really weird this has never
happened to me before so we're gonna
have to meet up again
and shoot the rest of this video i'm
getting super creeped out
i'm not too worried but my mom's really
nervous right now
i told her that we had to reshoot some
stuff and she goes no you shouldn't do
it you just shouldn't do it
okay are you ready to let back into this
let's do it
so it's christmas and i am
uncontrollably excited which is not a
good combination for following
directions
when i hear don't come down the stairs i
immediately leave my room to go see
what's happening
i see my mom and my grandma both lying
at the bottom of the stairs
apparently my mom had been carrying a
pile of presents down the stairs
when she tripped over the cat and fell
then her mother
my grandma came running out to see what
happened that's when mom yelled
don't come down the stairs the series of
bangs and thuds belonged to grandma
who had fallen down the stairs
attempting to rush to her daughter's aid
so i ran back to my bed holding back
tears because i was so scared and i had
no idea what was going on
at some point an ambulance came and took
my mom and grandma to the hospital
while my sister and i were taken to a
family friend's house that was a weird
day
it wasn't until later that night that we
got to go home and see mom
but grandma was still in the hospital my
mom had messed up her ankle
really bad it was completely black and
about three times its normal size
we learned that grandma had broken her
femur which is the bone in your thigh
and she needed emergency surgery and
ended up in the hospital for six weeks
later later that night we finally got to
open presents
but i didn't even care that it was
christmas anymore i was just so thankful
that nothing worse had happened
so a year passes it's the holiday season
again
and my mom my sister and i are
decorating the tree my sister pulls out
that
weird darth vadery looking ornament out
of nowhere
my sister decides that darth vader is
the reason for all of our bad luck and
we shouldn't hang him on the tree
even though i always thought it was a
little weird it was just an
ornament we argued for a little bit but
she insisted
that we not hang it on the tree however
i was a very bratty younger sister
and i wanted to prove her wrong later
that night when she wasn't around
i hung the ornament on the back of the
tree so she wouldn't see it
fast forward to christmas day that year
we had a wonderful breakfast
i got all the presents i hoped for
dinner was a spectacular feast
and it was overall a really great day
after our family friends had left
i was getting ready for bed and my
stomach started hurting
my mom and i decided that it was
probably just because i ate a lot of
dinner
and that seemed to add up but the pain
kept getting worse
i'm lying in bed crying from the pain
and my parents are
frantically googling the symptoms to
find out what's wrong with me
for the second christmas in a row an
ambulance comes to my house but this
time i'm the one being taken away
we got to the hospital and i was so
scared because a handful of doctors
had come to diagnose me and none of them
could figure out what was wrong
however every single
one of them did ask me is it possible
that you're pregnant
what i was 13 years old
i haven't even kissed a boy yet hearing
that question
over and over again just made me so
frustrated i was in pain and i wanted to
know what was wrong
they decided to give me an ultrasound
anyway this revealed
that my appendix had ruptured i was
immediately whisked away to surgery cut
two
me waking up in a room i didn't
recognize
which is not very comforting but
the pain was finally gone i was only in
the hospital for three days
the nurses all called me the poster
child of appendectomy
eventually i went home and i just laid
in bed for another day or two
as i'm recovering i think to myself how
did i get roped into this family curse
what did i do to deserve this no
no there's there's no way
my sister was right that ornament
that strange weird little darth vader
ornament
my sister said don't put it on the tree
what did i do i put it on the tree did i
do this to myself
regardless i knew what needed to be done
my mom my sister and i decided
we were gonna bury him we burned sage we
put an angel statue on top of him and we
surrounded it with a circle of salt
i'm glad to say my family did not have
the same bad luck after that
we had beaten this curse once and for
all we had no idea
this strange seemingly innocent darth
vader ornament had been wreaking havoc
on our lives
for years a couple years after the last
incident
we moved out of that house so i honestly
don't know what's become of darth vader
but
if you live in a suburb of portland
oregon and you find a
weird glittery thing while digging in
your garden
first comment below and then burn it
watch we're gonna put it up on youtube
and and the whole like internet's gonna
crash
i never saw my friend again and this is
that story
so it was many years ago and i was
walking my dog in brooklyn
one night a little uh tiny white jack
russell chihuahua
it was very very hot and i just wanted
to go home and i was saying make poopy
make poopy i have no empirical evidence
that this creates poop but it was what i
was doing and he had finally pooped and
we were gonna go back home and if you've
ever lived in new york
this summer can be very sultry and
disgusting and i just wanted to get
inside when i see this guy
walking towards us down the street with
a little dog on a leash my little dog
charlie gets very excited like
wagging getting down on the ground the
other dogs excited now i have to talk to
this total and complete stranger
uh about nonsense because we have two
animals at the ends of ropes that want
to sniff each other's butts we start
talking
just sort of talking about the weather
and he says oh i was just in texas i was
like oh i'm from texas he's like oh what
part and i was like san antonio he was
like i was right neither we had so much
great mexican food oh i miss the mexican
food don't you love the guacamole man i
love the guacamole they don't know how
to do guacamole here am i right
we're just like going back and forth
it's been like half an hour our dogs are
just sort of like chilling next to each
other like
checking out the block at one point i
finally tell him i'm like hey i live
right here why don't we hang out
sometime
and he says oh well um
and there's like a weird pause like i
don't know why he's not saying yes let's
do that
he's like well i'm um i'm moving away
soon i say oh
that's fantastic where are you going and
he says i'm moving to belize
and i'm like oh my god you're making
your american dream come true of leaving
america good for you
and he says yeah i've been going there
scuba diving for years
i love it i'm just gonna like go there
and just float in the ocean and i'm like
that
is amazing earlier he had mentioned that
he lived with uh his dog and his
girlfriend and i was like oh
are they gonna go with you to belize and
he got real quiet again like i said
something really wrong
and he says oh they're not coming with
me
i'm kind of like okay this is weird it's
real quiet
and then he just blurts out i have
terminal cancer and i only have six
months to live
[Music]
and i kind of don't like know how to
respond
and he can see me flustered and he
immediately starts kind of like spinning
out like he starts apologizing he
explains to me that
you know he's been having to tell family
members and friends this information
for months and people have cried and
screamed and he feels like over and over
again he has to comfort them and he said
it was so nice in this moment to tell
you
a total stranger and be okay about it
but he starts to apologize and he's kind
of getting tears in his eyes about it
and i want to calm him down so finally i
just blurt
it's okay i'm a storyteller at which
point like the ghost of myself exits the
front of my body walks around and kicks
my own ass like he just basically
confronted me with his mortality and i
was like i have a hobby
and then i freak out oh my god i mean
i'm so sorry that you're dying
not that you're dying hey hey no no no
it's okay telling you this
my experience my story what i'm going
through
was really wonderful to say this to a
stranger and i honestly think the world
would probably be a much better place if
everyone told each other their stories
and i said
yeah i agree and we stood there for a
minute
and made some small talk and then he
finally said well
i've got to go and i said okay well take
care and he
opened his arms and he hugged me and i
said goodbye
like goodbye you know we turned around
we walked opposite directions and
literally i probably wasn't 10 seconds
away from him when i burst into tears
like and i remember my little dog being
like what because animals they don't get
immense like sobbing they're like what's
happening do you want to play i get
upstairs in my apartment and
my boyfriend is there and he's like
davey what happened and i'm like
well i just was like walking down the
street i looked at this guy so we
started talking because of our dogs and
he said he's gonna die of cancer
and he's like calm down the next day i
woke up
and i couldn't stop thinking about him i
did what you do
in you know the 2000s when you meet
someone uh with a terminal disease
i befriended him on facebook and they
sent him a little message i just said
hey it was nice meeting you and over the
next six months
i watched this facebook page and i
literally saw his experience in belize
just through images that changed in his
profile pic and his banner pick
i saw beautiful trees uh swaying on the
beach i saw
these sort of underwater pictures of
this beautiful like azura ocean i saw
like stingrays and starfish
and after about six months the picture
just stopped updating
and i knew what had more than likely
happened is that kevin had had passed
away
now during this time i had actually been
really sick too
i had crohn's disease and i got down to
like 117 pounds i had been in a bad
place
but my life has started to change i was
feeling healthier and i was really
really hitting storytelling hard
i started teaching storytelling i would
use the story of meeting kevin
as a way to tell students or people i
was coaching or directing
about the importance of sharing their
stories you know people would be working
on stories about
domestic abuse or really personal loss
and when they would doubt it
i would oftentimes share this anecdote
about kevin it was probably about two
two and a half years after i met kevin
when one day i was on facebook and you
know facebook had just done that thing
where they
redesigned the interface and it made you
feel like a senior citizen like where
are my old messages like
banging and stuff and i finally found
this thing i didn't know was there was
like a sub
trash folder under a like spam
kevin had sent me a message uh the night
that we met
and all it said was it was so nice
talking to you
i'd love to continue this friendship
here's my number
and i immediately burst into tears and i
was so
angry i was so frustrated thinking how
did i like miss this chance to maintain
this friendship and
i put charlie on a leash i went for a
walk and i was probably halfway down the
block when i saw
a neighbor of ours and she could tell i
was upset and she's like what's wrong
and i was like ah well
you know about two two and a half years
ago i met this guy on the street with
cancer and i'm telling her the story
her face shifts and she says oh
are you talking about kevin that jerk
she tells me the story of kevin a man
who had subletted her apartment
with his girlfriend and their dog a
couple years earlier him and his
girlfriend
were going to part ways he was going to
go to belize he was going to get her
kind of settled and that she was going
to go and move west
kevin was going to put her stuff in
storage anyway he went to belize and
when she came to the storage unit and
the apartment it was all empty because
kevin had sold
all of her stuff to feed his crystal
meth addiction
kevin did not have terminal cancer he
was a drug addict
i don't know how he developed this lie
i did find out that i was one of many
people
in the neighborhood who had met kevin
one night and held him while he cried
uh and they cried maybe he was so caught
up in his addiction
and the lies around it and the money he
owed people and the jobs he lost
maybe one night he just tried it out you
know he just wanted to see
what is it like to say i'm dying and
someone held him and hugged him
and it felt good and i come away from
this conversation and i'm so
angry and i go upstairs back to the
computer i sit down
and i look and kevin has sent me a
message
on facebook and it just said hey what's
up i click
on kevin's profile kevin moved back to
new york
he's a foodie there's pictures of him
like eating chocolate cheesecake hashtag
yummy
i am just like in a rage like the
sadness that i had felt
down on the street talking to this woman
became this kind of like
like as i look at this like who the hell
does this guy think he is but then the
thing that really hits me
is like not so much that he betrayed me
but
i told the story of him to people who i
was teaching and when i think about
having used this story to do that i'm
just like i spread this like figurative
cancer ironically do you know what i
mean like i
used the story of this dude to impart
the importance of truth
to people and it was just a flat out lie
it made me think about the importance of
stories and why we tell them
i think meeting kevin served a purpose
in my life
and even though the story that kevin
told me was a lie
the way that it made me feel wasn't
once upon a time in my not so distant
past
i had a stalker this is that story
okay so as you can see or nazi
i guess i'm going to be anonymous for
this video this was a pretty scary time
for me so
i think it's just best if we do it this
way
here we go so one day i'm eating at this
restaurant and this guy comes up to me
have you ever
thought about modeling he asks and we
get to talking whatever image you have
in your head of this person
you're probably right two words
sunglasses
inside let's call him john
he explains that he works for a local
modeling agency
he shows me their website looks legit
and he says that i should think about
joining
to be honest modeling was something i
had always considered
pursuing so i decided to hear him out
after all
isn't this how people get discovered in
my head i'm thinking
even if this guy isn't legitimate plain
and simple
i just don't work with him john doesn't
have a business card
so he asks for my number harmless enough
i
think so i give it to him we'll be in
touch
he says and then he leaves a few days go
by
and via text we arranged to meet up
again to talk about the specifics for
how this whole modeling thing would work
okay
this is where things start to get a
little bit strange
we meet in a coffee shop i sit down and
i see
a stack of papers sitting next to him
okay so to get started we'll need to get
you a comp card
no professional model can show up to a
casting without a comp card
i can set you up with a photographer
blah blah blah blah for those of you who
are unfamiliar with the modeling world a
comp card is basically a model's
business card to quickly backtrack to
anyone who is watching who's like what
are you doing
get out of there i did do some research
beforehand
apparently there's a common scam for
models where
someone says they'll make you a comp
card but then the photographer will
charge you a bunch of money for the
pictures
so in my head i'm thinking i know what's
going
on here if they need photos from me i
can just
get a photographer friend to take them
for free
actually you know what he says suddenly
there's a casting call for a shoot
right now we should definitely go i'm
like no i
can't right now talking my way out of it
also i didn't even have a comp card yet
john was already contradicting himself
okay well here's a contract
you can go ahead and sign it and we'll
just look for more casting calls
i look over the papers my name is
already
filled into the contract and it's
spelled wrong
not to mention it's a two-year contract
and to top it all off the name of the
agency was
completely different than the name he
originally told me
my bad vibes meter is off the charts
i just need to get out of there i
explained that all the info is wrong
we can't do this right now i try to
leave but he
keeps pressuring me about this contract
i'll send you a fixed version
what's your address i give him my email
no your address okay
so at this point in my life i was doing
a lot of freelance work that
involved invoices so i was constantly
giving people my address to
send checks to so you know up to this
point i was just like
you can have my address and you can have
my address everyone can have my address
so i did it i gave him
my address i leave the coffee shop
i go home and i look up the company that
was on the contract
the website is so bad
like comically bad i send the url to a
friend of mine who is
actually a model and she basically tells
me to
never talk to this guy ever again i was
officially
done with seeing where this goes over
the next few days i get a few texts from
john trying to schedule a time to get my
comp card pictures taken
i don't respond at first but he keeps
contacting me i
say that i'm sick and that i won't be
able to do it right now
enter a new character in the story we
should call her
diana i start to get emails from diana
she works for this agency
they need my measurements and are asking
when i can get started
i don't answer any of these i'm just
trying to distance myself
thinking that maybe they'd lose interest
in me
about a week goes by i get a
photographer friend to take pictures of
me
for my own comp card i actually don't
hear from
john or diana for a few days
okay finally some breathing room here
one day i'm home alone hanging in my
apartment
just watching tv suddenly there's a
noise coming from the front door
like someone's trying to open it no
knocking
just the turning of the doorknob i
freeze
someone is trying to get into my
apartment my heart is pounding
my eyes are glued to the front door
after what feels like
an eternity the noise stops i
think they're gone but then i hear a
slow
quiet rustling a single sheet of paper
is being slid under the door
i hear the person walk away
and they're gone i could barely
move but i eventually summoned up the
courage to
go pick up the paper it's a sheet of
like notebook paper
and on it is a handwritten note
it's from the agency and it's how they
haven't heard from me in a while and
need to get in contact with me so we can
book more modeling gigs and stop
losing money this has one thousand
percent
gone too far i wait a little while
and then i decide that i'm gonna text
john i
don't work for you please leave me alone
he acts like nothing happened he jumps
right into other casting calls
and how i still need a comp card enough
with the cop card
i tell him my friend already took
pictures of me
stop contacting me in the meantime i
needed to tell my roommates what was
happening within a day or two
my photographer friend gets an email
it's from a completely new person
so i guess we can just call her regina
to paraphrase the email says leave
my name alone are you kidding me
i have no idea how they got my friend's
email or why they told her to leave me
alone
now i'm getting really mad leave my
friend
out of this i never had nor ever will
work for you i have almost no doubt that
john
is behind all of these emails and every
time i would stand up to him
it seemed that a new fake person would
just
pop up days go by i'd be home with my
roommates
and there would be random knocks on our
front door
we were scared to get our mail or even
take out the trash
to be honest i was scared to walk alone
at night
i eventually receive an email from john
telling me
i'm fired he also told
me to stop contacting him i for one have
never been fired from a job that i never
worked at
so that was a first in the meantime
i finally decided to tell my mom i was
hesitant to
up to this point because i knew that she
wouldn't take it lightly
i kept a lot of this to myself because
it was confusing
maybe a little bit embarrassing and
above all
really scary i needed a support system
to beat this guy
so i tell my mom and of course she's
freaking out
and is like we need to report him i'm
still getting emails from john and diana
telling me that i'm fired
in fact this was literally every day
okay now this last part of the story
gets a little confusing
if you weren't already confused enough
one day i get a new
email from this girl regina if you can't
keep track
this is the girl who told my friend to
leave me alone the email says
is someone named john harassing you
because it's happening to me too
and i think we should work together to
stop this wait
what i answer by saying i want to
believe you
but i don't she tells me that
john is using her identity to harass
other people with fake emails she also
tells me that jon
isn't even his real name to her he was
going by
a completely different name between john
fake
john diana fake regina i don't even know
who to believe
but she tells me she'll prove that she's
real
via a video call i decided to take her
up on it
and it turns out she is real
just a regular person like me who got
caught up in some
weird entertainment scam she was so nice
and we actually got to bond over how
crazy this whole experience is
we both agreed to contact the police and
stop this
once and for all the next day or so
after talking with
real regina my friends and my family
i take my story to the police you can't
see my face right now
but i am rolling my eyes they weren't
able to do
anything nothing i tell them about the
emails
the texts the coming to my apartment
well
he never came into your apartment so
there's nothing we can do
what do you want me to invite him inside
for tea to be honest
i was pretty defeated by this i
thought i had this figured out but they
wouldn't even listen to my full story
a few days go by my roommates and i are
still
on high alert especially after not
getting any help from the police
one day my roommate is taking out her
laundry to the laundromat
she closes the front door behind her and
notices a parked car
outside of our apartment building
there's two men
in the car now i had told my roommates
what john looks like so
that they would know what to look out
for it was him
it was john he was in the car parked
outside of our apartment
with another random person by his side
thankfully
my roommate immediately recognizes him
drops her laundry
and whips out her phone to try to get a
picture of his license plate they notice
what she's doing
and then they speed off
after that i never heard a single thing
from him
again not from him not from diana
not from fake regina nothing to
anyone who's worried i've since moved
apartments
and am feeling safe again did i think
any of this terrifying stuff was going
to happen to me
of course not did i make some mistakes
along the way
absolutely was it my fault though during
the beginning of this whole experience
i didn't really take it seriously i
thought i could just
ignore it enough for it to go away and
it ended up turning into something that
put myself my friends
my roommates and my family at risk
i've always been a very independent
person
rarely asking for help or rarely
admitting when i feel
unsafe or scared it took a lot for me to
admit those feelings
and tell others what had happened to
anyone who's watching this
please be careful watch out for yourself
and if you ever find yourself in a
similar situation
please tell someone i almost died from a
cough
and this is that story um okay
yeah there's no better way to say this
so one night
june 2017 i am
masturbating in bed and uh i start
coughing up blood
i'm like have i ever coughed up blood
before no
is this okay probably not so i call
9-1-1
and they send an ambulance one of the
emts when they're checking me out like
presses on my stomach
and she's like is your stomach always
this distended i'm like okay i don't
have a beach bod right now but like
it's a little insulting i'm at the er
and the doctor asked me like all the
standard questions am i a smoker
have i been sick like what's been going
on and at the end of his questions he
asked me if there's anything i want to
tell him
that i think might be relevant i'm like
okay uh
there's no way that this is related but
i was masturbating
uh is that part and he's like no there's
no way that has nothing to do with it he
was very polite about it so they give me
an x-ray and
let me go i'm walking out of the
hospital and the doctor comes running
out after me
yelling my name saying that the
attending physician saw my x-ray and
wants to do a ct scan so they do a ct
scan
they see a cloudy patch on my lung and
they decide to quarantine me under the
suspicion that i have tuberculosis they
keep me quarantined in the er for a few
days
they run some tests the tests come back
negative
i don't have tuberculosis so they let me
go i'm feeling good
i go get popeyes for lunch because hey
i'm alive and popeye's is delicious and
then later that afternoon i go to an
open mic
because i hustle baby on the way to the
open mic i call my grandmother i'm very
close with my family
and we didn't want to worry my
grandmother so i just wanted to call her
to let her know that
yes i had been in the hospital uh but i
was okay and as i'm on the phone with my
grandmother
i get this rattling feeling in my chest
and i start coughing up blood again
like a lot of blood like more than
you're thinking right now okay i'm
freaked out i see a friend
walking into the open mic i sort of flag
her down uh cause i'm scared
and i don't want to be alone um we get
into a cab we go to another hospital
the er doctor tells me that unless i'm
coughing up like a cup of blood
it's not an emergency there's nothing
they can do for me
it pretty much feels like an emergency
have you ever seen er doctor
a character in a movie coughing up blood
they tend not to make it but it is
enough of a concern that they make me
wear a mask the whole time
so they don't want to get sick but i
don't know what's going on
no one knows what's going on thursday
afternoon he sends me out into the
streets of new york to just
cough up blood on my own hey have a
great weekend friday june 16th
my mom set up a couple doctor's
appointments for me in manhattan the
first one an internist he tells me
there's a flesh-eating bacteria in my
lungs
but that i'm pretty much okay and i
should just
go about my life until we can figure out
what's going on i'm a little reassured
so between my first appointment and my
second i decided to go back home to
brooklyn to pack a bag
to go and stay with my parents while i'm
on the train i feel that rattling in my
chest again
i have a feeling that i'm going to start
coughing up blood again but because i'm
polite i open up the doors in between
the train cars
so i can cough up blood onto the tracks
i keep
coughing blood even as the train pulls
into the station so i get off the train
and i find a trash can on the platform
and i just
post up no one stops to help me or ask
if i'm okay
but i don't blame them what would you do
if you saw someone coughing up blood
it's like more than the last time so
each time
it's more and more blood when it's over
and i catch my breath i take a few
selfies because i'm a millennial
and i call my mom and i tell her i don't
want to die
standing on the train platform she tells
me i'm not going to
and i tell her you can't say that you
don't know that i keep
coughing up blood and everyone's telling
me i'm fine
how is this fine i go home i pack a bag
and i make it to my second doctor's
appointment i had taken a bunch of
pictures on the train platform to show
to the doctors
so i show this doctor a bunch of
pictures of blood that i've coughed up
and he's like
why are you showing me these pictures
i'm a doctor i know what blood looks
like
he tells me we're gonna do a procedure
called a bronchoscopy and they're gonna
do it first thing
monday morning why is medicine a nine to
five coughing up blood
is 24 7. he tells me to go home to my
parents place
so now for the third time a medical
professional has told me to go home
so i'm like lying on the couch that day
was the day that my sister's boyfriend
was planning on coming over to my
parents place to ask for their blessing
to propose to my sister it's a great
time
everyone's celebrating sipping wine
eating cheese meanwhile
i'm lying on the couch wondering whether
or not i'm gonna die
i reach for the brie and someone's like
hey maybe we could make a plate for him
so he doesn't have to touch the food
with his coughing up blood ass fingers
anyway party's over um i go to sleep
about 2 a.m i wake up to another
rattling feeling
in my chest i call for my parents my mom
comes in
with a bowl and i just start coughing up
blood into this bowl
and i don't stop for like a while
and i just keep coughing up blood and my
mom is there with her hand on my back
telling me it's gonna be okay and i'm
mad at her
because this doesn't feel okay when it's
over
there's enough blood to fill up like
multiple bowls
so now i understand
you can't tell your son that you don't
know if he's gonna die tonight
and i'm grateful that my parents were
there for me and were strong for me
and put me at ease because there wasn't
really anything to do
the next morning i wake up with a fever
of 103.
my parents call the doctor they tell us
it's time to go to the hospital
they admit me to the pulmonary icu and
i'm like yes
finally something is happening they're
at least taking this seriously
they just observed me that night
saturday
i stay in the hospital sunday afternoon
there's a doctor talking to me and my
parents they've done another test for
tuberculosis
it comes back positive five minutes
later i'm in the or
and they decide to put me under general
anesthesia
they send a thingy up through my groin
just try to stop the bleeding but
apparently the infection was so advanced
at that point
so they put me in a coma and removed the
infected part of my lung
four days later i wake up from a
medically induced coma
the doctors are going with tuberculosis
when i graduated from college i took a
job teaching english in china then i
sort of backpacked around asia for about
six months after that the going theory
is that i picked up tuberculosis
somewhere in asia and then it sat
dormant
in my system for about four years the
cdc has basically declared me
legally gross you have to report
tuberculosis because
uh it can be an epidemic so the doctors
are ready to release me on like a friday
afternoon but the cdc has to approve
my release and they don't work on the
weekends go figure and meanwhile by the
way
my family my friends they're all
visiting me everyone has to wear masks
i'm also grateful that i was on my
parents insurance by the way
because having tuberculosis if you have
it like me
can cost around like three hundred
thousand dollars
so i know a lot of people in my position
wouldn't have gotten the care that i got
and would be
much worse off so i've got like the
weekend the cdc hasn't yet approved my
release
one day i think it's a saturday i go to
the bathroom
i've got my phone i've got the wi-fi
password
i'm pretty stoked that i'm alive so i
decided to give myself some
celebratory me time and
uh i forget that i have a wireless heart
monitor strapped to my chest
and the thing about wireless heart
monitors is that they can't tell the
difference between an
orgasm and a heart attack so the nurses
come rushing and they're banging on the
door
i'm like uh it's occupied they're like
we know this is your hospital room
i'm like i'm having a bowel movement
they're like okay i can't believe i'm
talking about
off in a buzzfeed video monday the cdc
comes to my room not only do they make
me basically promise
to stay at home they send a
representative
to come watch me take pills every day
that's how serious this is i forgot to
mention that i was in the hospital
during my parents anniversary
father's day and my sister and her
soon-to-be fiance's housewarming party
really ruined a lot of good times for
everyone
despite everything that happened that
summer was like the best summer of my
life
my sister did get engaged in italy i was
there
it was beautiful i took an amazing bike
trip with one of my best friends in
montana
right before our other best friend's
wedding i stood by his side
as he married the love of his life and i
looked super hot doing it because here's
the thing when you get tuberculosis and
you're in the hospital for like two
weeks
you lose a bunch of weight um yeah
i almost died but i also got a lot of
thirst traps out of it
i was on a flight to russia it turned
out to be the scariest flight of my
entire life
this is that story at the time i was
living in russia and i was flying back
home from a winter in the u.s
i didn't want to fly for multiple
reasons first all flights were canceled
because of a volcano that exploded in
iceland and the ash made it dangerous to
fly so we were one of the first flights
to be allowed to fly over iceland and
well didn't sound safe second i just
watched the first episode of lost so i
now know that planes can be split in
half people get sucked out
i don't want to fly to be honest i've
been terrified of flying ever since i
was a little kid my mom freaks out on
planes so i guess some of it may be
rubbed off on me she does that thing
where she grabs the seat handles with
all her force which is
not that much and she just holds on so
the day came when it was time for me to
fly back to russia when we got to the
airport i was begging my mom to cancel
the flight and go home i had a
terrible feeling about this flight and i
know i have terrible feelings about all
flights but this time
it was terriblier but we had to get home
so my mom grabbed my hand and dragged me
onto the plane i wasn't gonna give up
just yet though
i was determined to get off the plane
i'd have thought
i was recently just watching x-men i was
watching a lot of things okay
maybe just maybe i could use my
brain to break the plane so i warned
my mom i'm gonna break the plane with my
brain
she ignored me so i put my fingers to my
temples and concentrated
30 minutes go by we've left the gate and
we're just taxing around the runway
suddenly the pilot comes over the
intercom and says we need to go back to
the gate
we had to switch planes because there
was an issue with the wheel i did it
i broke the plane with my brain my mom's
trying to figure out if she has some
sort of x-men kid i'm trying to figure
out what to do with my newfound powers
so yeah thanks for watching this is my
story i have super power just kidding
there was another plane
unfortunately my powers weren't enough
this time we taxied sped up
and we're flying so i look out the
window and we're literally
flying we're in the air there's nothing
there's nothing under us i don't
understand how this is i'm just in a
metal object so i'm trying to calm
myself down i get comfortable in the
seat i start sifting through the little
seat pocket
i'm so bored i grabbed the safety manual
i'm seeing people with their head
between their knees life jackets like
raft boats water slides and
spoiler alert you're supposed to put on
your own oxygen mask before you help
others
i can't keep reading this it's starting
to scare me again so i decided to go to
sleep to avoid all my problems because
if anything happened i could just sleep
through it so i passed out
all of a sudden i wake up the plane is
shaking
people are crying all the lights are out
holy sh what the [ __ ] is going on
stewardesses are running around with
flashlights in a panic
this is lost i was like mom what's going
on please tell me what's going on she
looks at me in full panic eric
go to sleep go to sleep so i'm trying to
figure out what's going on and i look
out the window
and i see fire
the wing of the plane is on fire so i
spring into action and immediately i
start
crying i thought i was gonna die
and the worst part is i predicted this i
knew this was gonna be happened yet i
got on the plane and now i'm on the
plane and now we're gonna crash and i'm
gonna die so the pilot comes over the
intercom again
there's a how do i say this
issue with the plane and we're gonna
have to do an emergency landing i'm not
a plane guy or anything but i think i
know what the problem is
it's uh uh we're uh we're on fire also
what's an emergency landing
so here's where she gets real i look at
the little tv in front of me that
sometimes has a little map on it the
little plane
it's got a little line and then you can
like see how much time you have left on
the flight it's just the atlantic ocean
everything is ocean nothing but ocean
ocean
i remember taking a deep breath and for
some reason the only thing i could think
to do was
fly this plane myself i had been using
my powers for evil before but
now i'm going to use them for good i
don't know why this made sense to me at
the time but i swear this is what
happened
i grabbed the imaginary steering wheel
and put my foot
on the gas pedal i mean i don't know if
planes have gas pedals probably not but
this imaginary situation did so i was
flying the plane i was also praying
relentlessly i remember promising god
that i would never cheat on a spelling
test again
i don't know how to fly a plane we're
gonna land in the ocean i'm gonna have
to use that dumb water slide
no i'm doing that thing where i'm
clutching the armrest like my mom the
plane was dropping fast not like it was
falling out of the sky or anything but i
knew the pilot wanted to land
asap the closer we get to the ocean or
the earth or whatever i can see there's
an island
it's lost we're in the middle of the
atlantic ocean where is there an island
but
it's green and beautiful and we're
landing on it the plane lands just like
any other plane not like crashing to the
ground or anything just a simple basic
land we all run off the plane as quickly
as possible as people in tin foil suits
enter the plane to stop the fire i was
looking around and
i couldn't believe my eyes none of this
looked real there was just a bunch of
rolling hills of lush farms
did i just crash land into a vacation to
give you an image this looks like where
the teletubbies live
turns out for all you geography fans out
there this was an island
within islands that was a part of
portugal collectively known as azorus
now that i was safe on the ground my
mind started reeling
what if we weren't near an island would
we would we have crashed into the ocean
whatever it's fine i'm alive it's fine
we ended up staying the night there and
then flying out on another plane the
next day
so finally after two and a half days we
landed in russia
the pilot apologized for the
inconvenience and offered everybody
gift cards sorry the plane kind of
crashed and like caught fire but
we got gift cards if you're thinking
about leaving the video do not leave yet
because i haven't even gotten to the
craziest part of the story
so i go about my life as a near plane
crash survivor and
everything's going fine until my friend
sends me a video from ellen so what's
the scariest thing you've ever done
it's leonardo dicaprio telling a story
flying out of new york to russia i was
on a plane to russia
engine catches fire i was looking out
the window and the entire
engine just turned into a fireball
was leonardo dicaprio on the same flight
as me
leonardo dicaprio was on the same flight
as me we
we shared a plane we almost crashed
together oh my god we have so much to
talk about like what row were you in how
was that
fire did you use the coupon yet then i
come to learn
we weren't on the same flight his flight
though oddly similar
landed back in nyc still that is [ __ ]
crazy that's an insane coincidence to
have with leonardo dicaprio is this a
common occurrence did i just waste
everybody's time
are you looking at me yeah why because
well apparently this isn't a very
original story
you told me this was a good story
i'm sorry